[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo
[Música]
con tan solo dos semanas en el cargo el
presidente de eeuu joe biden ha firmado
nueve órdenes ejecutiva sobre
inmigración bajo la premisa de deshacer
las malas políticas de trompe la casa
blanca claro que no todas son medidas
con efecto inmediato y que las reformas
tomarán tiempo los anuncios del gobierno
de bailén son esperanzadores para
millones de personas que esperan en eeuu
una regularización de su situación y
para otros miles que aguardan una
respuesta a sus solicitudes de refugio
en las zonas de la frontera sur la
reunificación familiar es bandera en los
propósitos de washington revisemos a
continuación más sobre los pasos del
gobierno estadounidense hacia una
reforma migratoria en la unión americana
yo vaivén continúa revirtiendo las duras
políticas migratorias de su antecesor el
presidente firma una nueva serie de
órdenes ejecutivas destinadas a reparar
el daño de la administración trump entre
ellas una para reunir a los casi 1000
niños que fueron separados de sus padres
en la frontera sur bajo la política de
'tolerancia cero' a la migración ilegal
del ex líder republicano
queremos poner en marcha un proceso de
inmigración aquí que sea humano que sea
moral que considere solicitudes de
refugiados solicitudes para que las
personas entren a este país por la
frontera de una manera que trate a las
personas como seres humanos
kritz vivos gimen binks la otra para
revisar una serie de políticas de la
hera trump como el procesamiento de
solicitudes de asilo además de una
revisión general al sistema migratorio
para garantizar que funcione
correctamente
los críticos de baire manifestaron su
miedo a que la reforma migratoria
provocará un efecto llamada de migrantes
especialmente desde centroamérica pero
la administración del demócrata ha
advertido que los cambios tomarán tiempo
este no es el momento de venir a eeuu
necesitamos tiempo para implementar
un proceso de inmigración para que las
personas puedan ser tratadas con
humanidad misma
estas nuevas órdenes pasan a engrosar el
voluminoso paquete de medidas
migratorias implementadas por la
administración by de entre las que se
encuentran poner fin a la construcción
del muro fronterizo con méxico y
proteger a los llamados dreamers jóvenes
indocumentados que llegaron ilegalmente
a territorio estadounidense cuando eran
niños
pero la paciencia de muchos migrantes se
agota pues ya son años los que llevan
esperando una solución y es que al menos
65.000 solicitantes de asilo fueron
obligados a esperar en mexico una cita
con las cortes de inmigración de estados
unidos en ciudad juárez varios de ellos
le piden respuestas rápidas al gobierno
by the end
en este refugio en ciudad juárez varios
solicitantes de asilo esperan poder
cruzar legalmente al otro lado de la
frontera
christie es hondureña lleva dos años
esperando la aprobación a su solicitud
de refugio para poder ingresar a eeuu y
reencontrarse con su hijo y pareja
porque no te dejan entrar los policías
no te dejan entrar mami me dice les pago
me dice para que te dejen entrar y son
cosas que a mí a veces me parten el alma
verdad porque una madre siempre quiere
estar con sus hijos y a veces las
circunstancias del país de uno lo hacen
salir pues así ella espera que las cosas
sean a otro precio tras el cambio de
administración en eeuu y la promesa de
reunificación familiar del presidente yo
vaivén pero yo le pido al gobierno de
eeuu que me permita estar con mi hijo
porque él me necesita y yo lo necesito a
él ya son dos años que tengo de no verlo
dos años de estar esperando aquí a que
me dejen estar con él y con mi esposo y
es que entre las órdenes firmadas por
bailén está una revisión a los
protocolos de protección al migrante que
dejó a miles esperando en mexico
una medida que afecta
prácticamente uno que hizo todas las
cosas bien esperando el tiempo aquí
premian los que sí cruzaron en
legalmente
y este experimento triste de estar aquí
tanto tiempo prácticamente como la
cárcel porque no hay nada pero mientras
algunos se resignan a seguir esperando
soledad dice que no puede hacerlo más no
sé yo no puedo esperar yo solamente
tengo ya ocho meses y aquí en méxico no
puedo porque ya después que quedaba y
poder nos cuesta mucho trabajo entienden
no quiero que mi niño aquí desesperada
decidí cruzar la valla fronteriza con la
esperanza de que los oficiales de
inmigración le permitan que su solicitud
de refugio sea revisada mientras ella
está en eeuu
sin embargo pese al afán de los
migrantes por una solución en el
gobierno de eeuu recuerda que el nuevo
sistema migratorio todavía está en
proceso y reitera que no es momento para
emigrar hacia el país y el dato de
inmigración de la semana 125.000 es el
número de refugiados que eeuu recibirá
cada año el dato resulta de una nueva
orden ejecutiva firmada por el
presidente joe biden y que supera ocho
veces la cifra establecida por el
anterior gobierno se trata del número
más alto de admisiones durante la última
década
hasta que inmigrantes de france24
seguiremos cubriendo la actualidad de la
migración en américa latina y en el
mundo en todas sus facetas los invitamos
a comentar en nuestras redes sociales
con el hashtag migrantes f24 sigan
conectados con más información en france
24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]